you
[Music]
hello I'm Spencer as I mentioned I'm a
data scientist at branch international
to differentiate a little bit we're not
the other branch not branch analytics we
don't do mobile analytics we use them in
our mobile app we do something a little
different which I'll go into in a minute
I'd like to talk to you about early
stage infrastructure and machine
learning and so let's dive in so first
of all as I mentioned I'm a data
scientist here I've been at branch for
about two and a half years after two and
a half years they finally put me on the
career site I'm hoping that in another
two and a half years maybe they'll turn
me around we'll see I've been involved
in a bunch of different stuff we're a
team of about 10 people now when I
joined it was I think four four
engineers that is so I've been involved
in a lot of different parts been
involved in primarily working on our
credit model but what that's meant is
there's a bunch of infrastructure
related to that we collect a bunch of
data from our users we have to clean
that data of course we have to develop a
bunch of features we have to build
models so I've been involved in the
whole end-to-end process I've been
involved in sort of building that up and
making sure it's a product that works
for the business so I'd like to try a
little video here we'll see how this
goes just to give you guys a little bit
of a sense about branch we're a slightly
different company than a lot of Bay Area
companies because we don't operate in
the United States so a little video this
is an ad that we put up in Nigeria that
was one of our customers in Lagos
Nigeria sort of interesting right we're
not operating the United States in fact
this company started in Kenya oops
you want to go back one more slide this
is our team in Kenya they're based out
of Nairobi we started in Kenya I guess
about four years ago now delivering we
started out delivering loans we still do
loans but we're now working on other
things we're trying to be mobile banks
we're offering a lot of different
financial services when we started
recently doing savings but we do lending
right now in Kenya Tanzania Nigeria we
started more recently in Mexico and
India as well so you can see you know
operating a lot of different markets
outside the United States primarily
focused on lending and primarily focused
on sort of people who are traditionally
underserved by banking institutions
people who are on mobile devices or use
mobile money who might have access to
sort of all that early technology it's
showing up but they haven't been
recognized by traditional banking
institutions yet so we found a great
opportunity we've got millions of
customers we've done millions of loans
at this point the the I guess the growth
has been sort of crazy because you know
turns out when you find a market that's
underserved it's easy to grow so anyways
our mission again to deliver world-class
financial services to the mobile
generation I want to give you all this
context because it really relates to
what we actually built in our machine
learning so a little bit uh now you're
just connected from this guy that's gang
this guy's disconnected there we go
great cool I'll click so a little bit of
our app you're not actually gonna be
able to download and use our app because
you're not a Kenyan with a national ID
in Kenya but you can at least see it
here so this is a little bit of our
signup flow we like we pride ourselves
and being really easy to install set up
and get started with a loan so some of
the stuff we'll ask for right off the
bat we'll ask for your name your
national ID your date of birth at that
point you're off and running if we like
what we see on your device will
potentially give you an offer we'll give
you a loan you can get that loan you'll
receive it in through your bank account
through your Mobile Money account
depending on the country and then
hopefully about a month later so you
repay that loan and move on to larger
loan sizes so one of the things you'll
notice in here you know I'm here to talk
about machine learning but where's the
data this user only entered their name
their national ID their date of birth
not a heck of a lot to create a credit
model off of certainly when they're
entering their own age you know you
can't really trust that piece of
information so what do we do let's talk
about what happens behind the scenes
with specifically our credit model piece
of infrastructure I've been primarily
focused on so steps that you'll probably
recognize that are pretty traditional
machine learning gathering data
generating a bunch of features you've
got a prediction our date is sort of
interesting we collect a bunch of phone
data we collect stuff like text messages
installed apps contact lists we of
course
so collect information from where you
click around in our app all this is
information that our users are willing
to give us permission to download
because they don't have access to normal
you know traditional financial
opportunities so in exchange we get all
this data and this is what we get -
credit score people on from this data we
extract a bunch of really interesting
information we extract stuff like your
bank account balance this sounds a
little surprising perhaps how do you get
a bank account balance from this data
well I mentioned mobile money in a place
like Kenya there's a thing called m-pesa
which a lot of the economy flows through
your texting money back and forth
basically you're getting receipts on
your phone in text message form turns
out when we download those receipts we
can see what your balance is we can see
your transactions we end up having a
source of more traditional financial
information that becomes really valuable
we look at a bunch of other things as
well you know social stuff like the
number of contacts you've got in your
phone whether or not you've read our FAQ
on the app that ends up being important
you know have you installed the Facebook
app sort of what's your ecosystem of
apps on your phone all these things are
features that we extract from that data
and finally of course we take all those
features we've got a you know some
traditional machine learning systems we
predict your likelihood of repayment on
a loan we think that looks reasonable
enough we're gonna give you a loan offer
you hopefully take it then a month later
pay us back assuming our predictions
correct but that of course is the crux
so with all this we've built machine
learning into our product but how do you
do it
that's a good question to be asking
right now specifically if you're sitting
in your seat going hey we're a small
company how do we do this so I'd like to
provide you a little bit of insight from
my experience building out well you just
saw that credit system building out in
the context of branch and building out
specifically what we're gonna call a
feature service so as you guys may have
seen in the slightly earlier talk to
talks ago only an hour or so ago Airbnb
is building this really crazy stuff
called bighead I look at this and go wow
wouldn't be nice to have this the
problem is I also see this it's a lot of
people involved you know there's a team
on zipline that's larger than the whole
engineering team at branch but we also
have a mobile app to keep and we
also have integrations we have a bunch
of other stuff we have to build we can't
afford to build infrastructure like this
and I assume a lot of you guys can't as
well so what do you do
what can the rest of us do we can be
strategic that's a really key detail you
can build machine learning
infrastructure as I hope I'll be able to
demonstrate to you it's not too too hard
to do but you have to focus you have to
pick specific problems where you can
deliver a lot of impact and where you
can actually get results achieved so one
of those areas that I'm going to really
push for you today is a really important
area to think about is what I'm going to
call a feature service focusing
specifically on developing your features
and making that a part of your machine
learning pipeline that really delivers
ok so let's talk feature service so what
does a feature service do for me I'm
gonna highlight I guess a bunch of
different points here but one of the
first things you'll notice as we go in
deeper is this is a thing that lets you
develop your features faster why we've
got consistent feature definitions these
help us reduce bugs we can speed up
feature calculations with a common
framework and we can make feature
discovery and sharing really easy these
were all goals that we set out to
achieve and we're gonna dig into a lot
more detail and how we actually went did
that ok so let's take one little step
back though I'm talking about a feature
service you're probably not quite there
yet if you're building a machine
learning system don't quite start there
you really do want to start simple in
the branch story we really started
simple we didn't even have machine
learning at the beginning and you
shouldn't necessarily either we had a
bunch of people we hired in Kenya who
did manual loan review they looked at
text messages and said hey can this
person receive a loan obviously not a
scaleable solution you got two million
customers you can't do that
but we started basic we had models as
simple a simple as linear regressions
running on Excel that of course we built
out eventually
we had systems built and Python we
started basic you're going to iterate
you're gonna patch things together
you're gonna make it a little bit more
complicated
but at some point the basics are going
to only get you so far a patchwork
system will eventually flatline this is
a demonstration of what our model AEC's
were ours weren't actually these numbers
they were better but about a year ago we
did find that we were getting we weren't
really able to improve on our model very
much we were adding new features we had
a lot of really great data but there
were a lot of bugs that were holding us
back there were a lot of issues and so
we couldn't quite get to that next level
we'd iterated on the basics but where do
we go from there so what do you focus on
beyond the basics you guys probably
recognize all these simple components of
a machine learning system I really
wanted to boil it down to the basics
here gathering data building features
these seem like obvious places to start
if you know the good foundation of data
if you don't clean data you can't build
clean features and therefore you can't
have a successful model in our world we
had decent data we invested some time
and made sure it was clean but we were
finding we had a lot of problems
building out really useful features
specifically we found that we had
differences between development training
and production these three environments
as we worked in them they were all
working off of slightly different code
that slightly different code of course
led to a lot of bugs
additionally we had inconsistent feature
definitions so we define features using
different code every single feature was
a custom piece of code built to build
that feature guess what a lot of bugs
we'd fix one feature you'd have another
one that was broken and finally feature
creation because of all this custom code
because of the patchwork system it was
becoming really slow and cumbersome in
particular training during training
feature creation became a major
bottleneck for us we got to the point
where to take a few days to train our
model a few days meant that guess what
we weren't really retraining our model
except on maybe you know we'd wait like
three or four months before we decide to
go tackle that again not really good
iteration process and as a result we
weren't improving our model anymore we
weren't able to spend the time and
energy and effort to do so so we decided
to invest in our infrastructure and
specifically we decided to invest in our
features and we decided to invest in
something I'm going to call a feet
your service okay let's finally get to
actually what that is what is a feature
service so in my definition you're going
to hear a lot of definitions probably
about what a feature services but then
what the one I want to give you is a
feature service is a tool that helps you
create a feature vector for a specific
object at a specific time I will talk a
little bit more about the timepiece that
might not be relevant for everybody but
the main idea is that you've got a
feature vector that's being created so
to give you guys a little bit more of a
concrete example this is the black box
of a feature service I might ask this
feature service for a bunch of features
related for to a given user in our world
this might return stuff like the average
bank balance or the number of referrals
or whether or not this person's actually
read the FAQ you know you'll recognize
you know some of these features are
numeric some of them might be
categorical some of them might be
boolean x' but together what's coming
back is all those features that I'm
going to feed into later parts of my
pipeline another key piece of the future
service I mentioned this time I might be
interested in historical features in our
case I might care about a user but it
might also care about what was that user
doing back in 2016 so I might ask the
future service for the users feature
vector back in 2016
again I'll get some numbers back but
they're gonna be slightly different it's
based on different data in this case
maybe the user had more money but they
hadn't made any referrals yet and they
hadn't read the FAQ not a good sign it
definitely shouldn't give them a loan if
they I'm ready FAQ okay so let's take a
look really briefly the API which I
think highlights some of these
components a little bit more deeply so
one of the first things you'll notice
these are three examples of requests
that we send to our feature service
really our most simple version of the
API one of the things you'll notice the
first bit is a feature name so a bunch
of different feature names in here stuff
like bank balance loan repayment a
second piece is a version we'll touch a
lot more in versions a little bit later
but versioning ends up being really
important for us as we fix bugs as we
modify these features we update them we
like to keep track of versions so we can
maintain backwards compatibility and
deal with other issues
next piece a primary ID in our case it's
usually a user ID it could be a loan ID
it could be a date in your world maybe
it's a photo ID anyways whatever types
of objects you guys are working with and
building your machine learning systems
around the primary ID would represent
that and finally we sometimes like to
include a date for historical purposes
so we're building a model and we want to
look back at historical features we want
to train off a store achill data will
include that date as well okay let's
answer a question that may be in your
mind right now
which is why the heck did you guys go
and build something custom this is a
really good question we're a small
company generally it's not wise for a
small company to build something super
custom especially if it's not sort of
their core front end product in this
case we about a year ago you know
realize we have this problem with our
features realize we really need to
improve the situation
we knew we need to invest in some
infrastructure but when we looked around
the ecosystem we found a lot of tools
but we didn't find any tools that were
working on features specifically that
may be changing in the future maybe zip
line becomes you know a big open source
thing like like air flow for example
that we could leverage but at the time
we didn't find that we found this gap
and so as a result we decided we really
needed to invest and build our own
system thus a feature service so let's
talk a little bit more detailed about
what we actually built I want to break
it down to three different components
the first component the first two
components are related to infrastructure
so we built both a server you know basic
server infrastructure for holding this
thing we call a feature service we built
some caching into the system and I'll
touch on that a little bit why that's
important and then the third piece is
inside that server we actually built an
additional Python framework we chose
Python O's the language we're all
familiar with pretty simple one for data
scientists to get up and running with a
lot of experience there so a Python
framework that actually delivers feature
definitions and creates the features
okay let's start diving in on the server
infrastructure I want to give you guys a
really good idea of all the design
choices we made why we made them and
then hopefully that gives you an idea of
what you could end up going and build
going and building yourself
so one of the first problems that we ran
into was data source dependencies as we
added new data sources for example data
source B here we found that there were a
lot of interdependencies between
different parts of our machine learning
system when we are in development we had
to connect to both data source a and
data source be in training way to do the
same in inference during production way
to connect all those data sources as
well in each of those situations we had
this dependency on the data sources one
of the first big wins of a feature
service is abstraction so the feature
service sits in the middle no longer do
I as a developer need to know about the
data sources that are downstream I just
need to know how to connect to the
future service
likewise for inference during production
we can connect to a feature service
rather than connecting directly to those
raw data sources the same process can
occur for training so first big win
abstraction a second big win for us we
found the way this problem with
recreating feature logic I mentioned how
we had a lot of bugs so one of the big
sources of bugs was that in production
systems we had slightly different code
than what you might have when you're
training these were slightly different
environments they had slightly different
requirements during development we had a
completely different set of code people
were creating custom code all the time
to develop the features that they want
to explore or model with this obviously
a big problem inconsistencies between
our training our development and our
production systems so again
centralization the feature service
brings all of those features together in
one location no longer are features
being computed separately in a
production system versus in a
development system in the development
environment you can connect to the
feature service and likewise in
production you can also connect to the
feature service the feature service is
running the same exact code to develop
the same exact feature again reducing a
lot of bugs for us we found an
additional problem machine learning was
working really well for our credit model
so of course you know the CEO is like
great machine learning this is cool
let's do more of it it's all pretty soon
we had a model helping us with our
customer service we had another model
helping us with collection
wait another model that predicted gender
which we needed for some regulatory
stuff there was an explosion of machine
learning at branch about a year ago
today two of those models are dead
they're in the dustbin because it turns
out it's hard to maintain all these
different systems with a lot of
different code so again feature service
a big win for us now all of that code is
living in one place when I go build the
first model for example our credit
service we've built a ton of features
out for credit scoring when we were
we're now in the process of building out
a long-term value prediction model
guess what turns out a lot of that data
a lot of the features that you want for
credit scoring are very similar when
you're building a long-term value model
with a feature service we don't have to
rewrite any of that we utilize the same
code the same central source of truth in
the future service and when we're adding
a third model say again using the same
features from the future service no need
to recreate anything anything from
scratch so this has been a big win for
us particularly on development time it's
meant that the CEO getting excited about
machine learning is something we can
actually deliver on now
so in summary just to sort of highlight
the winds from the future service and
the server piece of infrastructure
specifically we got abstracted data
sources we have shared features and we
have consistent features so let's talk a
little bit about caching now and feature
storage so we ran into a problem where
we were we found that we are recomputing
features users keep coming back to our
app we're an app that is you know drives
repeat usage and those users would come
back asking for a new loan another new
loan another new loan each time they
come in we're recomputing a bunch of
features first time they come in we
compute a bunch second time we recompute
all those same features again we're
throwing all that information out they
might come back a third time again we'd
recompute all of those features this
ended up being a big strain for us both
you know in terms of money and you know
server capacity but also you know this
was a slower process for our customers
because there had to have all these
really slowly calculated features
recomputed every single time so another
big win from the feature service is this
was a central source of truth we could
connect to a set
well data storage system so in addition
to the server itself the feature service
we built well we utilize a feature
storage in this case it's something as
simple as like DynamoDB database so
feature storage is there basically what
happens is when a feature comes in when
we compute it we can save it to that
cache when we request that feature again
we go straight to the data source and we
don't have to recompute we can simply
pull it from storage there's great side
benefits from this which are you now the
central source for all of the features
that have ever been computed and guess
what
analysts get really excited about all
that data this became a really good
source for analytics purposes looking
back historically and saying how did
features change over time it also when
you maybe solve the zip line talk
earlier they did a lot of monitoring off
of their storage system it's also
enabled us to do a bunch of monitoring
so features change over time you want to
know how they change you want to see if
features are no longer relevant all of
that is enabled because you're storing
your features in one central location
okay and then another big problem that I
mentioned early on training was a
bottleneck for us nowadays with this
feature storage serving as a cache when
a user first shows up we perform that
initial inference we compute a feature
vector for them we store it when I show
up and I want to develop a new model or
play around with that LTV model we're
working on I can go straight to feature
storage and pull those features no
longer do they need to be recomputed I
don't need to know how to do that I can
just go straight to feature storage and
utilize those and then finally the big
really really big win for us was when we
actually go and do training again we're
going back to the feature storage the
features have been computed we've saved
ourselves as a result we've gone from
multiple days of training like two days
worth of time just to get our features
built down to a few hours again because
we're not actually running a that
computation it's already been done for
us the user showed up two years ago we
got features then so big speed-up for us
by using a little bit of simple caching
so a feature storage in summary you know
we've removed recomputation of features
we've enabled analytics and monitoring
and as a result of all that we've also
increased our training speed which is a
big problem for us
let's talk a little bit about what we
actually built with this so as I
mentioned earlier dynamodb for future
storage a pretty simple database to work
with the feature service itself is a
simple flash game app deployed on
Amazon's elastic Beanstalk something
that hopefully you guys will notice is
none of these tools or anything that
fancy these are all pretty out of the
box in our case Amazon tools you could
use whatever cloud provider you've got
but what I really want to highlight here
is that it was simple well you know
there are a lot of different things
built into this the tools that we
actually end up using for the
infrastructure are pretty basic okay so
to summarize all of that simple
infrastructure solve many problems for
us this is a diagram of it all put
together for you and just to sort of
refresh ourselves feature service served
as a common source for features it
allowed for data abstraction and then
the feature storage itself allowed for
caching analytics and monitoring and
finally we kept it pretty simple we
utilized third-party tools we utilized
open source frameworks we didn't build
anything too fancy or custom there we
use something as simple as flask to get
this whole thing deployed okay cool so
let's zoom in a little bit you're
probably now wondering what happens on
the future service on that server itself
what's running in there how do we go
from text messages to bank balance for
example good question let's dive in so
inside one of the other pieces that we
built inside the server was we built a
framework this ended up adding a lot of
other benefits for us so this framework
we composed of a few different component
pieces within the framework we have this
idea of a feature probably not too
surprising but a feature is composed of
an extractor or two or three and a bunch
of transformers the basic way that these
work together for us is an extractor
connects to the raw data source pulls a
bunch of data there's code to deal with
all the different data sources all the
different nuances of our different data
sources
that's all bundled up in this object
called an extractor we then have a
series of objects called transformers
which are modular components doing
simple things like filtering or mapping
or reducing so to
drive this home I have a little bit of
an example this is one of our features
average bank balance our average bank
balance pulls from text messages using
the extract SMS you'll remember that
text messages in our world actually
contain bank balances a little bit
mind-blowing but that's that's what we
have so extract SMS pulls those text
messages at that point we've got a
series of transformations and a pipeline
we might pull out the specific text
messages from banks we might pull out
the balances from those messages using a
different transformer and then we might
average those together using a third
transformer collectively this defines a
feature for us and at the end result of
all that is we get a number spit out
which is your average bank balance one
of the cool parts about all this is that
these components are modular they can be
shared so you can imagine our average
bank balance feature looks very similar
to our maximum bank balance feature they
both share and a common extractor they
both deal with parsing the text messages
the same the only piece of changes is a
little bit of math at the very end so
that modularity a big win it meant that
you know we had common code that can be
tested and reliable and it meant that
when we wanted to develop new things we
could use those same components we
didn't have to start from scratch every
time okay so let's look a little bit at
some code on how we actually did this
one of the big differences one of the
lessons learned from zip line is that we
actually decide to stick with Python so
you notice this is some Python code up
here one of the first things you'll
notice at the top is everything is built
from some base classes we have for
example imported here feature and
transform the base classes of course
have a lot of common logic one of the
really cool side effects of having some
base classes and a common framework is
we could do some interesting automated
testing again helping us reduce some
bugs you'll notice that the features are
versioned
so all of the transforms all the
extracts that we import they come with a
specific version attached to them we'll
talk about this in just a minute and a
little bit more detail but that ended up
being a really important piece for us
you'll notice this of course is all in
Python so the advantage of course of
building a framework in a language as
simple as Python is that you've got all
the flexibility of something like Python
in this case I've added a com
meant to this class it's just a list
nothing too fancy but all the
flexibility that is Python is still
there I can still import numpy I can
still import scipy I can utilize all
those things in my various features that
I might want to build down here we see a
chain of transformations we see the
extractor and then there's a series of
transformations most of these are common
transformations that somebody else wrote
and I just imported except for the last
one here where I decided I didn't really
want an average I wanted a weighted
average so again we're working in the
world of Python it's all pretty flexible
I could go and build my own custom
transform stick that into the pipeline
as well so it's a data scientists coming
in you can see if I want to add that new
feature it's not going to necessarily be
too too complicated I need to know maybe
which data source I want to pull from I
need to have a rough idea of the
transformations I want to add but the
amount of code that I end up writing and
the amount of sort of debugging and
testing that I need to understand and
all of that is pretty limited because a
lot of other people have built those
components and I'm just utilizing them
okay so versions I mentioned versions a
few times let's actually talk about
versioning so one of the big benefits of
a feature service again that central
source of truth
one of things that we found of course is
that features have to change over time
bank balance for example we discovered
bugs all the time and our features you
can imagine a buggy bank balance version
one we've got a credit model trained on
version one the buggy version of bank
balance somebody comes along and says
hey I want to fix that well in this
world you can fix it they're going to
make version two you're not going to
make our model our old credit model
out-of-date instead you're gonna make
version two of bank balance the bugs
been fixed and at that point we can then
go and train a new model that works off
of the fixed feature and we can point to
that so in this world we have a process
for fixing our features a process for
updating our models we don't deal with
this weird world of inconsistencies
where we have an old credit model that's
trained on a buggy feature we have to
leave it all up and running because the
model can't be updated when we update
the future so that's versions in a
nutshell of course we can also just
leave the old credit model running we
can have the new credit model running
alongside it
both of them can point back to bank
balance each of them just picks a
different version so all of that
supported by the future service
yeah a nice little benefit side benefit
of having features
so in summary of all that feature
definitions you saw they're consistent
there's a framework new features are
really easy to build off of all those
shared components and versioning allows
for backwards compatibility and bug
fixes as I demonstrated so bring it all
together we've seen these things data
abstraction common source the simple
framework the caching the analytics the
monitoring and then internally of course
we have consistency easy development and
versioning so at this point you're
probably asking should I build one of
these myselves
myself a few questions you might ask
yourself a few questions that we found
the answer was yes his feature quality a
problem for you this was definitely a
problem for us about a year ago this is
an area we really felt we need to invest
in are all of your data sources complex
and varied if you're working off of a
single data source and it's pretty
simple you can probably just keep your
pipeline pretty simple but for us we
were adding a lot of new data sources we
really need to deal with that situation
are you trying to support more multiple
models you know our CEO got excited
about machine learning wanted to see it
everywhere I imagine that that's the
case at many companies and so for us you
know we needed a way to support
development of new models exploration of
new models and and supporting them in
when they're actually in production
finally are your features difficult to
compute for us our features were pretty
slow to compute and so the speed-up from
a cache was really really important
we of course have benefited greatly from
this thing future generation time
dramatically reduced we've fixed a lot
of bugs as I mentioned we can make new
models without rebuilding our feature
set new data scientists can come in and
contribute features and code within
weeks of joining this is something we
experienced recently a very exciting
benefit we didn't even think about and
of course we've been able to then
iterate and improve on our model
performance so that of course was the
end goal of this whole process so what
should you take away from all this
hopefully well you can take away is that
a small company can build something too
you don't need to be air B&B with a lot
a lot of engineers to build this thing
the trick however is to be strategic and
if you're going to be strategic I
recommend
in a future service a lot of benefits
for us and hopefully you see some
benefits in this for yourself as well
all that said stay informed come to
conferences like this you know go to
meetups all those things because Airbnb
may open source big head pretty soon
there may be other things on the horizon
this is a common problem space where
there aren't a lot of solutions yet so
keep your keep your eyes open if
somebody else builds something you don't
necessarily need to build it yourself
so all that I want to thank the team
that worked on this we dentists Dave
Tingting Nick and myself again a pretty
small team working on this thing and all
these people contributed if you'd like
to get in touch I'm Spencer at branch Co
and I'm happy to take any questions can
you talk more about the details of the
feature store like what are the keys in
there and in particular it seems like
date is going to be something important
how do you handle when you have quickly
changing features yeah so I guess a few
points there
I can maybe go back real quick - let's
see if well yeah I don't know this
technology whatever we're not gonna
worry about it so one of the things you
probably noticed is that we've got this
idea of like a primary ID you know
usually in our case it's user ID so
that's certainly one of the primary that
is the primary key and that feature
storage is even expect a secondary key
it's really important for us is time I
mentioned this idea of how you might
always be requesting features at a
specific time
sometimes you explicitly call out the
time that you want them but if you don't
do that
its implicit that the time that you want
it is now and so when we then store
those features in the future storage
you've got say user ID and then the time
that the feature was actually created so
those are sort of the two keys and then
of course the feature itself is you know
could be any number of things it could
be you know boolean x' or whatever you
know again DynamoDB all these no sequel
tools give you a lot of flexibility so
we just have a blob that is basically
you know a JSON blob that is our feature
itself so those are sort of the two
primary keys yeah something like user ID
and then the date where it's actually
created and there was you the second
part to your question as well do you
need to do anything special to handle
quickly
changing features because if you have
these two primary keys then you might
have one user with a date every single
day because of a feature that changes
yeah so for us I mean our time scale
right now for feature changes is usually
on the order of like we're dealing with
loans loans that last a month so we're
dealing with our time scale tends to be
more like a month so in our case we just
store whatever the features were at that
time point we store them but you can
imagine if things are changing really
quickly maybe you just want to store the
updates one of the things that we end up
doing with our text message data in
particular I didn't talk too much about
how we actually architect our data but
that ends up being a really important
part in terms of dealing with time so
with text messages for example those are
constantly updating as you might imagine
and so we just store the updates we
store if you're familiar with SCD tables
we storm in an SCD format I think type 2
but the idea there is that you have a
text message that shows up we keep track
of the data it showed up and then if it
disappears we keep track of the date
that it was deleted and the combination
of those two dates lets you sort of
figure out what the state of the world
was at that given time but you're never
having to store there's a sort of
another idea which is that I might store
a snapshot of the text messages every
time I get them but you end up
duplicating a lot of data so if you're
getting a ton of data coming in it's not
changing too much something like SCD
tables you can look up the Wikipedia
page is a great explanation that's a
good place to start
you might just store the updates yeah
thank you yeah thank you um how strict
are you in pushing all like data
transformations into the feature store
like if that somebody wants to do some
weird imputation strategy or interaction
between two features are those stored as
completely distinct features in the
store or does any of that ever happen in
the modeling area yeah that's a good
question so you know I think one of the
one of the interesting ideas that we've
been exploring is this idea of we sort
of realized that you don't this Ennead
to separate out your model from your
models from your features themselves a
key idea behind this might be like if
you take text messages we're all text
message data is interesting but what
happens if you instead embed it now
you've got a much more interesting data
format you can work with that much more
flexibly it's you know it's a vector
numbers it's a lot easier to work with
that of course implies a model however
like if I'm gonna train an embedding
model where do I put that I could put
that inside the feature service and so
one of the things we've been exploring
is let's have a feature that takes all
the text messages and creates an
embedding for it and then you might use
you might use that embedding to develop
other features so I might use that
embedding to build out my my um my
credit model and so you've then got a
dependency hierarchy where you've got
you know extractors transforms defining
one feature if you got another feature
that then calls that feature to use that
data so we haven't really built that
stuff yet but you know that's I think
very much something that could be built
would be relatively easy you can imagine
sort of a graph framework of feature
interdependencies where you compute
features utilize them in other places
and I think putting models into the
future service makes a lot of sense
there's no reason that a credit score
shouldn't be a feature in our world for
example a credit score could be a
feature into a different model it could
be a feature into the LTV model for
example so yeah no reason not to do that
yeah just got to build it hey I got a
couple questions but I guess the first
of which is do you ever generate
multiple features in a single like
Python thing because you know your
example with the average and the max
there's a lot of computation that goes
into extracting from SMS and then doing
all that junk right hmm do you guys
batch that together and in a single job
yeah so a concept I didn't really touch
on but with our API we don't tend to
call individual features that doesn't
really make a heck of a lot of sense
because what you just talked about like
I don't want to pull all those text
messages I mean that ends up being a lot
of data for us to pull so we usually if
I'm gonna ask if I'm developing say I
want the feature set for the credit
service I'm gonna ask for all the
features at once so we've this idea of a
feature set which would be predefined it
might include Bank you know maximum bank
balance average bank balance and so on
all of those guys are gonna be
requesting text messages and so there's
actually a second layer of caching in
here which is the extractors all have
their own cache as well or not not a
unique cache there's a shared cache for
all the extractors so text messages end
up getting pulled once even if they're
getting used for multiple
features so that deals with a lot of
what you're talking about we haven't
addressed the idea of transformers being
really complicated they tend to be
pretty simple in our world but you can
imagine if a transform took a long time
to compute maybe you'd want to do some
caching in there too but we haven't
really explored that option yet for us
it's really the data pole that's the
slow part so we do we do include a
little bit of a caching later there cool
yeah yeah you could imagine doing I mean
if you did your hierarchy of features
and that whole crazy graph thing you
might utilize the fact that a feature is
cached you know that embedding for
example that I mentioned this an earlier
example you might cache that and then
utilize that and you know ten different
places to develop a bunch of features
you know all interesting ideas yeah yeah
okay thanks
the other question I have is do you
differentiate at all between like
feature serving versus featured
generation like if you get a you know
request on demand just to run from this
model for this one person you might need
to go calculate those features on demand
but if you're training a model you need
to go and generate a ton of this data
all at once for to create your training
set yeah do you guys have a concept of
that yeah so I think I think there's
sort of a few things that I didn't
explicitly mention but are implicit and
sort of our problem space and one of
those is that we are doing online
inference a user shows up they want a
loan right away we need to credit score
them right away there's of course the
batch use case which is pretty common
for I think a lot of companies really
machine learning ends up living in batch
during training of course it lives in
batch so for our feature service in the
API we have I think the primary API is
the one I showed you which is hey we
want features we need them right now the
secondary one is you're going to pass in
a collection of primary IDs a collection
of dates that you want and the features
that you want so when we're generating a
training sample we say hey we want these
you know we want these 150 features we
want them for these you know half a
million users we want to met these dates
for those half a million users and those
will be the dates that they you know for
example took out a loan in the past and
that then ends up being requests so
there's a second API that is sort of our
bulk API okay yep thanks mm-hmm and we
have time for one more question
any questions on the other side of the
room
I was wondering how um how far back you
store the data for the date part and how
many versions and how do you decide that
basically yeah that's a good question
so we I think by virtue of you know only
having a few million customers haven't
had to throw any data out or deal with
the cost of all that we've been able to
keep it all so we haven't thrown in the
out I think that yeah if you're gonna be
throwing data out you probably threw out
the old stuff I guess you know for us a
lot of what that means is you know our
business was very different three years
ago we were getting very different
customers so that's we don't actually
even use that data in training anymore
but data storage is cheap I don't know
you look at the s3 costs like you might
as well hold on to it you know it's dirt
cheap to hold on to all that so what was
that those first prettier question was
the second so you've got yeah hmm
urgency side yeah how do we decide what
versions to do so versioning we version
whenever we changed the logic so bank
balance was the example I used in my
slides while bank balance the idea is if
the logic that defines bank balance
changes enough that the value that would
come out could change and you need to
version it and that's really important I
mean just to sort of hammer home that
concept I think one of the problems that
you can sometimes get between folks are
really familiar with engineering and
really familiar with data science and
like machine learning systems is that a
model is immutable once you've trained
that thing it's up it's running but it
expects certain data in certain formats
and so when you go and change the
underlying data when you change the
future definition when bank balance all
of a sudden you used to include cents
and now you round it off well the model
expected the cents to be present and so
it's gonna get confused and it's gonna
get confused in ways that you might not
notice for a while either which is
that's a problem that we've run into in
the past you know we changed our
facebook features and our Facebook
changed their API our Facebook features
changed and six months later we said oh
wait six months ago things broke you
know that's a very common problem so
so the future service versioning happens
whenever we change the logic whenever we
fix a bug and generally because it's
easy to version if we're changing
anything in there if somebody goes in
and says hey this thing's running this
feature is running really slow let's
optimize it we say ok
you can optimize it let's version it and
so we'll copy paste we'll start a new
version of it just to be on the safe
side it's easy to do why not be on the
safe side so that's sort of our
philosophy at the moment
[Music]